hello everybody how's everybody doing
today as dr. dashi mentioned my name is
a key ohashi I'm with the palo alto
research center park and i'm very
excited to be able to speak to you today
and tell you a little bit about what
park does and a case study on an
intelligent system that we are working
with a an asian rail operator in
implementing in real life and as if
you're familiar with park you know that
you know we do a lot of research very
few of them actually make make it out
into the real world so we're pretty
excited that this is is headed in that
direction I just a little bit of more
background on myself my parents are
Japanese but I was born in the US
although i've spent about five years in
japan as an adult mostly in the venture
start-up and venture capital area and
I've been at park now for almost six
years and just prior to park I was at a
venture capital firm in Japan Tokyo
doing venture investments mostly for for
overseas investments from Japan and then
there was a great opportunity a park to
do business development and try to bring
technologies over to not only Japan but
the rest of Asia as well and so I moved
back over here and have been been here
for almost six years now so I you know
I've got some prepared slides but please
feel free to ask any questions as we go
through i like to keep these things
interactive and if there are things that
are not clear or if you have questions
about them feel free to just raise your
hand and let me know what your thoughts
are ok so how many of you are familiar
with park have you you've heard of park
ok so park is that's great that's great
park is it stands the Parc stands for
palo alto research center and and it's
actually very close to here it's about a
five minute drive if you're not worried
about looking for for for parking
and if you get lost this is what the
sign looks like out in front of the
buildings but we're very close to to
Stanford and we are a subsidiary of
surak's and I'll tell you a little bit
more about how we became a subsidiary as
opposed to just a research group but as
you can see here so here are some of the
things that Park has invented in the
past or a research center we've invented
things like the laser printer the first
personal computer Ethernet the graphical
user interface itself that's something
that was also invented at park and and a
few other things I won't go into too all
of these that are listed up here but as
you can see park was incorporated
actually in 2002 so I'm going to pop
over to the next slide park itself was
formed in 1970 as a research division
within Xerox but then we were spun out
and became a company in 2002 and even
though we were spun out we Xerox still
owns us a hundred percent so we have a
really good strong connection with Xerox
but we're because we're company now
we're able to do a few things that we
were not able to do in the past and you
know people wonder why would you spin
out a company and then make it a hundred
percent subsidiary don't usually spin it
out so you can get external investors I
mean that's a really good point and I'm
going to back up to actually to the
previous slide you can see a lot of
these technologies on here the laser
printer was great for Xerox right easy
rock is a printing and copying company
there's a new thing called laser printer
which prints things faster and cleaner
makes perfect sense so they were able to
commercialize that and subsequently paid
for the park investment many times over
PC workstation actually not so much
Xerox actually tried to what they did
commercialize the pc and where was the
first company to actually commercialize
the mouse but quickly you know Xeroxes
model was not really focused on small
personal devices or personal computers
they were used to selling enterprise
machine
Eames printers and so it didn't work out
and they got out of that business
Ethernet lyrics was not interested in
commercializing networking equipment to
begin with and so Bob Metcalfe the
inventor of Ethernet he eventually
decided to just leave Xerox and he
started a little company called 3.com
and became very successful with ethernet
graphical user interface many of you may
know the story behind this there was a
gentleman by the name of Steve who heard
about this and decided to come take a
look now many people don't know that at
that time Xerox had an investment in
Apple Steve's company and so through
that relationship he had access to a lot
of the research that we were doing he
came he saw he borrowed and the rest is
history so the reason why I'm talking
about this is is that you know in the
past when there are technologies that
fit into printing and copying then then
it was relatively easy for Xerox to take
and commercialize and derive benefit
from it but if there were things that
didn't fit into that model things kind
of leaked away or however you want to
phrase it but Xerox wasn't able to to
capitalize on that very much so the
decision was made in 2002 let's spin
Park out make it a company and give Park
the ability to work directly now with
other companies other organizations to
commercialize the technologies that
Xerox is never going to commercialize
itself and so that's the reason for that
change park itself is about the numbers
a little bit old it's about 350
scientists and engineers and ethnography
furs and business staff most with PhDs
we have a large number of different
projects both in hardware and software
we have multiple business models to try
to take these technologies into the real
world and we have a patent portfolio
about 2500 patents and about 150 new
patents every year any questions so far
everything okay
who pays the bill that's a great
question i'll get into it more in a bit
but essentially xerox gets to pay only
about half of what we cost right so
basically our bill is is is our is our
revenue right so xerox puts in about
half based on the research that we do
for them and then the other half comes
from working with private industry
government and then licensing of our
patent portfolio so that's actually a
great question that leads into this so
this is a very typical kind of process
for taking rd and then moving up into
product ization sales support park
really focuses on this really early
stage I mean we're we say rd but we're
really big are in little d we have a few
hundred scientists and we work in really
small teams we come up with new ideas
you know we use the the Lean Startup
method agile method of iterating through
lots of different projects and trying a
lot of things out and if they work we
keep them moving forward if they don't
we try something else and for the rest
of this commercialization process we
rely on our partners now the partners
are the folks that i just mentioned
other companies xerox included the
government the US government funds a lot
of our projects and then spin outs you
know startups and spin outs are also the
partners that help us commercialize and
the reason why we do that is you know we
feel like we're pretty good at the the
research part we have a lot of really
really smart scientists and we do a lot
of the early stage research and we try
things out in the lab and see if they
work we're not so good at the
engineering you know the development the
engineering the commercialization you
know obviously sales and marketing
things like that we don't have those
capabilities so we we really decided to
focus focus on on this piece and that
you know that allows us to just continue
to come up with new things and not have
to scale up to be able to do these types
of things yes research university on a
recent oh there's a great question so
the research in the university and
research
Park the types of things we research I
would say are pretty similar Park does a
lot of fundamental research basic
research on technologies you know things
like networking protocols new materials
new processes I think probably the
biggest difference is that Park has a
PNL meaning we have to make a profit or
at least break even every year so we
have this this business pressure to take
what we do and make money off of it at
least not lose money and so the way we
do research is I think it's a little bit
more commercial focused and that when we
come up with new ideas we don't just
think about the technology about fifty
percent in the evaluation of that
technology and that project is actually
a business decision meaning if we come
up with this or we invest in this
technology is there a chance for it to
be commercialized is there a potential
market you know three to five to ten
years into the future and if we can't
answer that or at least become you know
fairly confident that there's a
potentially a market then we don't do it
right so we don't just do research for
research sake or blue sky research we
really we've from the very beginning
there's always a business case that goes
along with the research and that's
that's probably one of the biggest
differences between a park in a
university and also Park pretty 2002 and
park post 2002 yes I'll be measured the
pml for the reasonable
it's all the time quarterly you know
what product by project I mean it'sit's
run like a business so each project has
a profitability target and obviously at
the end of the quarter everything gets
rolled up and gets reported to we're not
public so Xerox gets those numbers and
then at the end of the year they expect
us to at least break even and and so
there's you know I'm not a researcher I
I have a business background and have
done a variety of different things that
startups I don't do any research and so
we have people like myself who have come
in and and had the experience of
commercializing technology and we have a
commercial business team that works with
the researchers both in the interactions
with potential customers as well as
evaluating the technology and thinking
about how to move that forward so here
are some of the things that we're
working on now the the specific topic
I'm going to talk about is is related to
big data but other than that we do a lot
of hardware a lot of other types of
research there's an energy research and
this this includes everything from
printed batteries to solar to an
advanced fiber optic sensor that we're
doing a lot of our research not
surprisingly is related to printing and
so we have things like printed
electronics we have you know build
prototypes of printed oh you know the
first integrated fully printed memory
we're doing now 3d printing with three
printed electronics integrated into them
so lots of printing related research as
the place that invented Ethernet we have
a strong networking tradition and even
today the biggest single project at park
is actually a networking project and
it's a technology we call content
centric networking and we think that
while we're hoping that this would be
the next generation internet basically
where we get rid of IP addresses and and
put instead of putting IPS addresses on
devices we will we would put content
addresses on content and do network
that way and and that's that's a whole
another topic but but it's a new way to
think about networking and we feel like
could be a really viable next-generation
internet digital design in manufacturing
so along with trend and 3d printing and
moving design and manufacturing into the
cloud we have a lot of projects
particularly funded by the government
actually around digital manufacturing
I'm gonna skip over this innovation
services for a second optoelectronics is
around lasers and LEDs we are creating
new lasers all the time new wave lengths
of lasers we were the first company
outside of Japan there were a few
companies in Japan that were further
along than we were but the first company
outside of Japan to be able to
manufacture a blue laser and we have
continued our research into new new wave
lengths of both lasers and LEDs and we
make those ourselves in our lab big data
analytics particularly around cyber
physical systems machines industrial
equipment things like that and this is
the have some examples of that cleantech
obviously related to energy but also
things like water filtration which which
is also surprisingly tied to printer
research and then some research and
health and wellness now the reason why I
skipped over innovation services is
because innovation services is different
than all the other areas and that this
is more of a consulting business for us
so we realize that being a commercial
entity since 2002 and thinking about how
to commercialize technologies ourselves
we realize that that's actually really
really valuable information to other
companies right other large companies
they have research centers or sent
spending millions if not tens of
millions and sometimes billions of
dollars in R&D and and not getting the
ROI that they would like out of it we
have a lot of experience and how you
know thinking about how to take
fundamental technologies emerging
technologies and think about new
commercialization new businesses things
like that so this is a consulting
primarily consulting service that we all
for two outside also internally but
outside and it's it's in particular it's
it's had a huge pickup in Japan and thus
we have a small office in Tokyo and
they're all staffed by these innovation
services consultants so here are some of
the companies that we've worked with
that are that were allowed to talk about
publicly we have a lot more that have
you know they said do too confident
confidentiality reasons they would not
like us to talk about in public but we
do work with as you can see a lot of
large companies and then some names you
probably never heard of because there
are some very small companies and those
are primarily are kind of to target
areas a large companies with very large
rd budgets and then the small companies
that are really focused on
commercializing technology okay so
that's the introduction portion of the
presentation any other questions or
comments up to now they're pretty good
all right so now I want to talk a little
bit more about yes sure you major Dalton
invasion services after the 2002 just
means there's how to find out so
flammable the way to consult the other
companies to make invasion we are
basically just using our own experiences
right so after 2002 we had to come up
with new processes for example new
processes for how you come up with
project ideas and then how you evaluate
those as they go through right you can't
now just think about the technology and
think about how good the technology is
we have to think about the market so we
have a process now where a new project
is you know almost pretty much all our
projects are thought up by our own
researchers they're not from outside
right so our researchers come up with
project ideas we develop them but then
there's an evaluation process for do we
continue to invest or or should we stop
it right and the evaluation process
prior to 2002 was really focused on
technology right is this an interesting
technology
is a unique and novel do we have the
capabilities and the competencies to
accomplish what we're trying to do
things like that right and of course
those things are very important than
their their must-haves but post 2002 we
actually have a whole nother half of the
evaluation criteria which is the
business side of things as I mentioned
you know what does the market look like
in five years and could this technology
fit into that market you know what are
the current manufacturers and current
vendors saying about these types of
technologies and so it's not just
sitting down in a room and discussing
those things it's going out and speaking
to end-users going to partner companies
going you know hiring consultants
bringing in entrepreneurs and residents
there's a whole variety of things that
we do to try to get this information
when we evaluate the technology and then
there's a process to go through how you
evaluate each project as well as how do
you evaluate your entire portfolio of
projects right and you know we did that
for ourselves and we realize hey that's
really valuable information for other
companies and so we it's it's it's all
pretty much based on the learnings that
we've had based on our experiences you
know obviously we take the frameworks
the Lean Startup frameworks things like
that that are out there and then we
incorporate them we use them we try them
out we we change them and then you know
we take what works for us and then you
know we then we make suggestions to our
client companies based on their
situation right so they're they're
tweaked obviously in each situation okay
so I want to talk about this specific
engagement that we've had with this
Asian rail operating company this is
going on about three years now about
three years ago we started working with
them and it's really run asset
management maintenance essentially a
maintenance of their equipment and they
wanted to do maintenance better for
their equipment this company is it's
quite big and they have a pretty big
research effort in variety different
things and one of the things they wanted
to do was hey we want to make our
maintenance processes much smarter more
intelligent they started you know so
with this big data phenomenon and
sensors getting cheaper and IOT they
started collecting data from their
equipment right so they put sensors on
their doors for their training cars you
put cameras underneath their trains to
take pictures of the rails as they're
going by they start outfitting the
infrastructure with with sensors and
they started collecting all this data
but then they didn't really know what to
do with that data so they had some
people internally playing with it
they've hired some consultants and they
got some marginal benefit and they came
to us and said hey look you know we've
got all this data can you you know can
we work together can you help us and
essentially what they wanted to do was
improve their maintenance processes so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
maintenance because Park also has a lot
of research and maintenance and not
initially in rail equipment not
surprisingly it's in around printers and
copiers we have a lot of if you you know
if imagine a printer or copier has a
little panel on it and that little panel
will tell you you know you're out of
paper or you're about to go out of toner
or your fusers about to go bad or the
roller has gone worn down that type of
information you know the piece of
component is not just telling you that
it's actually has to be calculated using
algorithms that are using the data from
the sensors that are in the printer and
a lot of those algorithms have been
developed by park and so we have a lot
of experience in trying to make these
printers and copiers
a little bit smarter so our vision
basically is to go from I'll go into
these a little bit more of a time
basement maintenance so if you can if
you just even just looking at the word
basically maintaining things based on a
certain set period of time to
condition-based maintenance which is
maintaining things repairing things
based on the actual condition of that
piece of equipment at that time and then
in the future self actualizing self
analyzing systems where the system's
themselves have the ability to analyze
what's going on with itself and then
adapt to the situation all right and
this could be a single system a single
component or it could be a flock of
components kind of working together to
respond to some kind of issue and this
piece is bolded right now because I
think this is kind of where we're at
where we're trending towards it i guess
we're not we're not really at
condition-based maintenance yet most
things are time-based maintenance and
I've gotta hear you know I've got a
prius right I think a lot of you have
cars maybe most of you and I would say
you know car maintenance is purely
time-based right you've got a manual
that has instructions about you know
when do you change the oil every 5,000
miles or five months and then you go and
take it in for a tune-up or repair every
30 50 75,000 miles etc etc now this is
there's not necessarily time but it's
set on a pre-determined these metrics
that really don't take into account
what's going on right if if i drive like
a maniac then i probably need to get my
oil changed more and i probably should
get tune-ups more often right if I'm
driving very very conservatively then
maybe I can go longer than this and so
the problem with time based maintenance
is that if you're too early with your
maintenance then you're wasting time and
money right you're you're doing
maintenance on something that doesn't
need maintenance but you don't know that
because you're not really thinking about
that and of course if you're too late
then you
you're in trouble right your car breaks
down on the side of the road and you
should have had that looked at a couple
weeks ago right so time bateman
time-based maintenance has a lot of
issues so there is a better way and that
is condition-based mean it's like we
said like I talked about you know
performing maintenance only when needed
right and this results in reduced
downtime saving costs I'll unnecessarily
repairs and then you can also if you do
it smart then extend the useful life of
that piece of equipment so how do you do
it so this is this is the kind of
intelligent systems piece of the
presentation and I'm not going to get
into the nitty gritty mostly because I
can't but I think it's really
interesting so you know think about a
system here I just Illustrated as a
black box but basically what you do is
you put sensors on there and you collect
data right so there's a lot of data
coming out of that whatever it is box in
the example that I'm going to talk about
it will be piece of rail equipment and
the data can be you know almost anything
but things like you know vibration
temperature of course if there's some
kind of gas pressure speed voltage if
there's electricity involved current
stress-strain shock you know there's a
variety of things you can measure right
and that can all be the the data that's
coming out that you you might
potentially use and then you build a
model right and the building of the
model this is where the intelligent
system comes in this is where you use
artificial intelligence and machine
learning to come up with the best models
and the best algorithms for that piece
of equipment and so what do you do with
the model a couple things right first is
diagnosed right diagnosis is from the
model you can figure out what went wrong
you know that that something was funny
with the sensor you know what's going on
right that's the that's the first thing
you can do and then once you get more
sophisticated you can actually say well
prognosis right what will go wrong right
so for the copier printer example if
you're if you run out of paper then you
know you ran out of paper
but here for prognosis you can actually
tell based on your paper usage when you
might run out of paper or another thing
is things like the roller and the
components inside your machine you can
based on what the feedback is from your
sensors you can say you know when you
might need to replace your roller when
your night need to replace your your
fuse or etc etc rights and that's based
on the models at you you come up with
you build and how do you do it there are
two main ways there's a physics-based
model that you actually build a
physics-based model inside the system
and your modeling out if a piece moves
here then it you know it causes a
reaction here etc etc or you do a very
data driven model where you just have a
bunch of data you come in and you figure
out where some of the anomalies might be
or you try to classify them based on
what that data is and you don't actually
know what's going on inside that piece
of component and then of course if you
add those together you can have hybrid
models which in most cases that ends up
being if you if you're able to spend the
time and resources on it ends up being
the most best method i still have you
any questions yes will absolutely do
that so I'm going to what I'm going to
do is for the way I've got three
examples and again I'm not going to get
too technical but I've got an example of
a data-driven one and then I've got an
example of a hybrid one where i actually
did both of these and combine those just
really quickly on the physics based this
is as deep as i'll go but you build the
model so when I say physics space you
actually will build it in assists in a
piece of software something something
like modelica and you build kind of what
this system might look like right and
and we're act like and then you validate
the model you know figure out that it
works well and then you actually augment
that model with failures meaning if
something were to go wrong if something
were to break in the system how would it
break right you have to teach the model
those things so you teach them all that
and then you compare what
get out of that model to actual data and
then you can figure out what's going on
on the data driven model you actually
don't know what's going on inside the
system right so for the rail example
I'll have an example of the door we put
some the client put some sensors on the
door and we got some data out of the
door but our model we use data driven on
that on that example and our model does
not know that it's a door and it does
not know that there's an actuator the
only thing the model knows is that
there's a bunch of data coming out and
then it tries to classify that data
based on some criteria that we give it
and you know in this in this example you
need a lot of data to train the model
essentially in the physics pace you you
need to know what's going on inside the
device but you don't need that much data
to actually build the model and that's
that's one of the key differences but
this is this is really where you use a
lot of the machine learning so the
machine learning is done here you take
the data and I won't go to into the
details but you segment the data into
different different segments that make
sense and then use machine learning to
extract these things called features
which then you do calculations on and
you classify these features and you
figure out if the data looks like this
then something must something must be
for example in the door case something
must be stuck in the door if the data
looks like this then the lubrication is
getting old and needs to replace and
I'll go into that in more detail detail
in a second so I'm going to now jump
into the collaboration example and
there's three examples here there's so
you know there's a lot of equipment to
to run a railroad and the the ones that
we looked at were the door the switch
machine the machine that switches the
rails when you're going in different
directions and then the rails themselves
because the rails themselves actually
will start deteriorating over time
develop cracks holes etc etc today they
wanted to know more about the rails okay
so the first one is around the door
and I don't have a whole lot of but
there's a lot of stuff on here and I
apologize for that I don't have a whole
lot of pictures but essentially you know
the doors are one of the largest causes
of problems and delays for four trains
right so one statistic is thirty percent
of all delays this is in the UK are
caused by the doors right the doors are
stuck someone is stuck in the doors
something is stuck in the doors etc etc
right and I think if you've taken trains
you may have experienced these things
particularly in Asia where there's a lot
of trains maybe not so much here in the
US and the failures are often do two
things that are undetected underlying
cotton or causes things that are stuck
in there like I exit like I mentioned or
maybe the guide rails are deformed the
the bolts that are holding the door have
started gone going loose getting loose
things like that right and so the this
company collected a lot of data from the
doors and eventually after looking
through all the data we we actually
realized that only one piece of
information was necessary to figure out
what was going on with the door and that
was the current the amount of current
that was being sent to the motor to the
actuator of the door and that's it and
based on that we developed models and we
use machine learning to figure out the
best algorithms and we were able to
classify the client wanted us to
classify each situation into i think
what it says seven underlying causes
right so you have a normal situation and
then you have seven situations where you
have something that's not normal so one
could be there's something stuck in the
door right another one could be the
lubrication is going vadik cetera et
cetera and based on the profile of the
current that is getting sent to the door
we they wanted us to classify or we were
able to classify what was going on in
that situation now why why is it current
important the current is important is
because if you if you have something
stuck in the door the motor is going to
try harder right and so you need to send
more current to the motor
and so now we know that there's
something weird going on and based on
the profile of how much current is sent
to the motor at a certain amount of time
each situation has its own signature
right if there's something stuck in the
door the profile looks one way if the
bolts are loose the profile looks
another way if the lubrication has gone
bad then the profile looks a different
way and we're able to figure out based
on come the algorithms and the data
what's going on and we were able to
achieve ninety-eight percent accuracy on
classifying the information and they
were they were stunned really and one of
the things that that was really we were
even surprised about is that so the door
as I mentioned has bolts obviously
holding the door into the frame of the
the car and they on purpose for this
test they on purpose loosened some of
the bolts and they said hey you know we
got this situation it doesn't happen
that often and then you know if you
can't figure it out no big deal but can
you you know can you let us know if the
bolts are loose on the door so he said
all right we'll give it a try we ran our
algorithms and surprisingly we were able
to tell that the bolts were loose and
furthermore was really surprising it's
not only were we able to tell that the
bolts were loose or not we were able to
tell which bolt was loose and they were
like they were they were on the floor
they said oh my goodness we never
thought never would have thought you
would have figured that out so what's
going on now is these are screenshots of
this interface that we're developing for
them so initially it was you know raw
technology we just developed a bunch of
algorithms and then there's a really
really clunky interface that we we gave
to them they said hey that's awesome but
we can't use it because we don't know
what's going on so we're now developing
a more slick kind of web-based interface
so that they can try it out and once we
finish this is the phase that we're in
now once this gets delivered and used
the next step would be then actual
commercialization all right so this is
an example of a data a purely
data-driven approach
the prototype will be done this year the
demo and then they'll use it and I think
probably next year if all goes well
they'll they'll put they'll pull the
trigger to go into development for a
production version so probably in a
couple years if if we if everything goes
goes goes smoothly so the second example
is a switch machine so the switch
machine is the the point machine is also
called the machine the thing that moves
the rails between the tracks when you're
going in different directions and you
know obviously this is a really really
important piece of equipment because if
it if it fails and you could have some
really really bad things happen right so
one of the things one of the challenges
here is that with the data-driven
approach you actually need situations
where something goes wrong right and you
need the data for the the fault
situation and you need the data for the
normal situation and then you build
models based on the information that you
have with these point machines because
they are such important pieces of
equipment they don't go wrong they've
already been designed and engineered so
that failures of these pieces of
equipment are very very rare and so you
have to wait 10 20 30 40 50 years for
something to actually go wrong with
these things so you don't have the data
for the fault situation right so I mean
of course you can do accelerated testing
where you apply heat or water or various
things to accelerate your testing but
obviously you're you're creating
artificial situations which are not
necessarily good for for your model so
here what we did was we said okay let's
let's so we're saying there's limited
nominal data meaning there's no data or
very little data for the failed
situation but we know what that machine
looks like and so what we did was we
built a physics-based model in the
system
and then we use the data that was
collected and built the best models we
could out of those two and then combine
those two together to create a model
that could then predict what's going on
with the system and this is another one
where you know we got 99 percent
accuracy on the on the dating they gave
us and so they were thrilled and and we
were thrilled and you know we really
showed kind of the benefits of a hybrid
model we're doing both model-based and
and data-driven approaches and then the
third one this is a really interesting
case this was purely data-driven as well
but a but we use a different technique
this is for the rail itself right the
rail surface itself so the rail gets you
know it's like the street right as you
as you drive the train over it it starts
wearing and sometimes they crack
sometimes they wear down sometimes they
they end up with these kind of wavy kind
of deformations on the surface you know
there's a variety different things that
can happen and so they always need to to
to monitor them and make sure that it
doesn't develop into something serious
so in the past well it presently what
they do is they inspect them visually
right you have to go and look at the
rails or you take pictures and you look
at the pictures but in either case
somebody has to do something and so they
say hey let's let's put some cameras on
the bottom of our cars and take lots of
pictures and that'll make things easier
which is what they did but then they had
tens of not hundreds of thousands of
pictures that somebody had to sit and
stare at every day and I don't know
about you but that's not the most
exciting thing looking at rails all day
that you could think about doing so they
said well let's you know we want to
develop a system that does the image
recognition and then the analytics on
that recognized image and you know this
was you know not something that we had
developed just for this project
coincidentally or fortunately for us we
have a big research area in image
processing not surprisingly due to
copiers and printers and so we were able
to bring that group into the project and
we had they gave us a lot of pictures
thousands of pictures there's two main
steps the first step is through the
image processing right so we went in we
process the images and then we turn that
digital into the data into digital data
and we basically were able to kind of
classify things look at things based on
the pixels on on each of these images
and then build a data driven model that
could classify again based on the
pictures what's going on with the rail
is the rail so this is an interface
screen shot at the interface but you see
the rail here and then over here it will
tell you is the rail in a normal
situation or is it is something wrong
with it something weird going on with it
and it's all done based on the machine
the computer does all that and here we
were able to get over ninety percent
accuracy on the true positives and less
than five percent on the false positives
and this is you know it's a huge help to
them because now if somebody looks at
the rail it's the picture of the rail
itself an expert they can figure out
instantly if something's wrong with it
they just can't sit there do that all
day for all their pictures so now what
this does is you can pull out the ones
that seem a little bit odd and then
present only those to the expert and
saves massive amounts of time and money
and so they were there were thrilled
with with that research as well
any questions in comments yes these
shows are flat buzzing force positive
yes it's not right this is this is good
this is good you don't want false
positives right false positives means
that you know flag something but it
wasn't actually something wrong with it
right good very surface detective very
see severe I see so the trick if it's
severe then it's pretty obvious right if
you have a big crack running down the
middle of your ear rail it's pretty
obvious and you don't need anything
sophisticated to tell you there's
something wrong with it right what we
wanted to do here is detect things that
were very very subtle right so there if
you think about it the rail has a train
it's outside right there's debris so you
know so this it's not just a very clean
picture you've got a lot of stuff on the
rail little little it's albeit small but
you've got you know little thoughts here
and there's rust and a variety of
different things and you have to ignore
all those right if it's a little bit of
rust and the rust isn't an issue for the
rail then you can't say that rust is a
crack right or the rust is a divot right
so you have to teach your system to
really look for the specific patterns
that match a issue right if you have a
small crack in the rail that's a big
issue that can be a big issue because
the crack will get bigger and bigger
over time if you have a little bit of
dirt on the rail that's not an issue
right so you have to be able to figure
out what looks like a crack and what
looks like a little bit of dust and
that's where you know the pot false
positives and true positives come in is
that sometimes you would classify a
little bit of dirt as a small crack even
though it's not right and and at the
stage that we're detecting it it doesn't
matter right in that case the rails can
be still used for probably many months
if not years but we want to detect these
things early so that we can then start
figuring out when do we want to do
maintenance and how do we maybe we want
to change design of the the Train of the
track or you know there's a variety
different things
can do if you notice these things in
advance sizes did you apply any kind of
evaluation or pay off by the scenario
yeah yeah that's a probability in what
this gentleman yeah no that's a good
question in this case no in this case we
are working with a technical team for
this company and they're really just
looking at unitech the the technical
issues but we definitely do that because
the next step in something like this
would then be building a maintenance
practice around that right and and to do
that then you have to optimize for the
time of the technician where they're
located how long it'll take to get there
how much that costs and things like that
and then so then you have to you've got
a whole nother set of variables that you
have to optimize for and we and then the
other thing is prognostics right so not
only is the situation the way it is now
but you want to know when it's going to
get to the point where you have to
actually do something right and so we
would then build in algorithms for
prognostics to figure out what's the
future look like and then build those
into the model to figure out then what
your optimal maintenance schedule would
be for example and that would then have
a lot of the economics built into it as
well and then you know we do that for
printers and copiers right all the time
is the repair person the service
technician the cost of sending them out
you know what should they be repairing
and looking at it on the same visit etc
etc because I I mean it goes into this
this whole business model of what's
going on with printing and copying
nowadays but really companies like Xerox
are now kind of taking or taking over
the repair portion of it just providing
everything as a service and so it's it's
they're incentivized to make these
things as cheapest and efficient as
possible right so when your repair
person goes out maybe you went out to go
fix some you know a roller that had been
worn down but you know maybe on that
visit you want to fix and replace a few
other things I mean that may not be
broken at that time but may break within
the next six to 12 months and then you
save the visit which you know will come
you know will comment at that off you're
off to your bottom line basically our
add to your bottom line hi yes capital
investment did the company have to make
in this system for new sensors out on
the out on the tracks and so forth was
that what they all did they already have
most of those or was it really that was
knew that it was so it's actually yes
and no it wasn't they had to put it in
its new but it was already in when when
they approached us right so they put it
in first because they're all excited
about big data and then they started
collecting all this data and then didn't
know what to do with it so then they
came to us and in a variety of other
people as well to help them look at the
data so that's happened but you know it
it's it's really just starting right so
they've outfitted these things but you
know they're not really integrated
they're there in the in the labs they're
not on operational trains for the most
part so there's a somewhere to come
definitely that's actually a very
interesting point but cause a lot of the
roads in Japan also have a great deal of
sensors embedded in the roadway and my
senses they're collecting a lot of
information and not really doing much
with it yeah yeah I think so question in
the back
where you live in your research yeah
absolutely because it's um you know for
things like this it's a pretty being an
investment just to put in the sensors
and so starting to work with a company
that's just putting in the sensors
you're probably two or three years away
from actually collecting data so it
definitely is a prerequisite for when
we're doing these types of analysis is
that you know you already have the
sensors in place and maybe they're not
the exact right ones necessarily but at
least you have data that we can start
looking at and then the next generation
we can say oh maybe if you put this type
of sensor you'll get better data but
even with your current data we can tell
x and y yes what was the game does it do
I see you guys
and then what yes yes so with all the
data with the data driven models you're
absolutely right the the data needs to
be labeled meaning if the data is from
us we need to know if the date is coming
from a piece of equipment that is acting
normally or if it's in one of the
various faults that they're trying to
classify and then what we do is we build
the models and we train the models and
then we test the models on a different
set to see if they're right you know
they work or not but you absolutely all
the data needs to be labeled and you
know for things like this when we train
using the the ground truth or labeled
data but then when we the outputs you
can actually just look and see you know
at the picture whether we've classified
them correctly or not so I'm pretty much
at the end I mean this is a you know the
the back of park we do things in big
data for industrial equipment for the
rail is just one example you know
printers and copiers of course but we've
got a project now working with an
elevator manufacturer to model elevators
you know we have a lot of image
analytics types of Big Data projects and
then a whole bunch of other projects
that we didn't even touch on today and
so you know my job is to find partners
for us to to to kind of take these to
the next level if you're interested in
any of these feel free to reach out to
me I hockey that's kind of my next
question okay future for this system so
this is what when was it implemented
fully by the Japanese partner so the
system is still in if I it's in a demo
phase right now a pilot phase I guess
right is a better terminology so they're
testing it internally with their
researchers and and some of the
maintenance people but it's not
implemented yet so the next step would
be once you get feedback from the tests
then to find a somebody else that does
system development because park doesn't
do system development and the research
team at the client doesn't do system
development either so it's do the system
development and the integration would be
the next step which now optimistically
would probably happen within the next
year or two oh no it just means we have
the door the door yeah well the dopamine
these these things we've got and then
you know we work on some of the we're
talking about some of the other things
but no not no I mean there's so many
things and there's a lot of things that
they haven't even started looking at
right like the HVAC system the overhead
wires I mean there's so many things
still that could be outfitted yes so
while we're speaking of things can you
tile that back to your general
definition of the Internet of Things um
so you know I think I owe teasy is a big
buzzword right now and I think a lot of
it will is still just buzz but i think
you know what what's exciting to me
about a project like this is that we're
actually using IOT and in this case I
think it comes in as the I IOT the
industrial Internet of Things but you
know we're showing that you can actually
get real value from you know all this
data that's coming in and it's not just
about sending you better ads or coupons
to your smartphone all right so that's
that's what i think is pretty
interesting exciting about these types
of things is that you know now we're
finally getting to the to the point
where yeah we are we can see real value
because this you know this will save a
lot of money in maintenance of course
but also it will improve service and
safety for for the passengers right and
as this continues to to develop you know
at the end of the day also costs as well
for both companies but also the
the passengers right so I think I don't
know if that answered your question
exactly but i think it's a it's a one of
it for us it's a really exciting area
and it's not just research it's actually
application and it's providing some some
real value out there that you know we're
trying to make the world a little bit a
little bit of a better place so achey a
park is involved in a number of
different technology be areas i know
that you've done a lot of work on
ethnographic research and i know that
part had things like a new kind of water
filtration system for water purification
that was really exciting how is it that
got this job was the kind of didn't um
the actual awarding of the job was it
because of you know something else that
the center had done or did you are you
exactly are you asked are you asking how
did part get this specific job with the
rail company or how did we get the job
with the rail company yeah so the rail
company I mean you know they had a big
need you know they invested millions of
dollars into equipment to gather
information and they had a they had up
well they have a pretty visionary leader
of that group that you know he kind of
is is on the leading edge of thinking
about CBM condition-based maintenance
and so you actually will see a lot of
publications written by him or
co-authored by him about CBM in rail and
so he wanted to make this vision a
reality within his company and so they
made the investment into outfitting a
lot of their equipment with sensors and
then they realize you know they need to
actually make investments into people
analyzing the data front coming from
these two equipment so they were looking
for partners and you know we happen to
have a pretty big effort into analytics
both here and in Asia and so we happen
to cross cross paths at one point and we
sat down and they say hey this looks
interesting and you know it started out
small
and we had a small feasibility where
they gave us a little bit of date you
know we signed a CDA and they give us a
little bit of data and you know came
back to them and said hey look you know
we can do something with this and so
then it kind of scaled up and then we
were able to do multiple different
projects and kind of you know went from
there yes sure well it needs a who owns
the pockets on the ideal it's not like
what's your future plug using same
technology we expand to other yeah those
are related questions definitely so
there's there's multiple ways to cut
this up but essentially there's two
types of there's two types of patents
right there's the the background
information the background patents the
things that we've developed kind of
prior to going into the partnership with
this company and then there's the
project IP the IP that's generated in
the project and the way our model works
is that when we do these types of
collaborate we call them collaborations
just because it sounds cool but
basically they pay us oh it's no it's
not it's not like a 50-50 thing they're
paying us and that's just how our model
has to work based on the way we're
structured but so they're paying us
right and we're developing things on
their behalf so and and and this is a
case-by-case thing but typically and in
this project is very similar what
happens is that Park still maintains
ownership of the patents that are
developed in the project but then for
the client we give them typically
exclusive rights to use that patent
within their field of use right within
their application so for rail for these
patents they can use exclusively but
maybe these algorithms work on on
elevator doors for example I don't know
we haven't tried it but other types of
doors not in rail and this company
doesn't happen to make elevators right
so we have then the right to continue to
use these patents with in other fields
of views which then you know you can see
we continue to build on our asset of IP
while providing the value to the
customer that they're looking for right
without conflicting with each other so
that's typically the way we like to
structure these things obviously you
know sometimes the client just wants to
own every
right and then there's there's a cost to
that right so there's a negotiation and
depending on how much you pay then you
get more access etc etc it's a big
secret um so yeah they in this case they
preferred to not be public yet you know
it's not so it's not they're not
obviously ashamed of doing this but I
think they you know they I've got some
business reasons why they want to keep
it confidential yeah it's a railway
operator in Asia so actually there are a
lot more possibilities for that than
there used to be yeah that's true ah the
cause of the regional dividing up and
and also there's a number of private
railways in Japan as well yeah um aki
was but your sense that the other side
the receiving side for this did they
have qualified people who could who can
run the software system and so forth
there was a lot of training involved for
them no I by and large they were
qualified I mean they're you know they
know a heck of a lot more about trains
than we do we know our is how to mess
with data and so there's there was an
extensive training and in fact you know
they were the ones really giving us the
requirements for what this thing would
look like and how it would be used and
so in some ways they were kind of
training us to to build the the pilot
version that that would be most useful
to them so they're very qualified that
you know the thing that they were
missing the most is the actual data
scientists right they didn't we have you
know depending on how you count in we
have about 150 data scientists at park
mostly with PhD so a lot of people
looking at data whereas within this
company I think you know they have tens
of thousands of employees and probably
just a
handful of people that you could call
data scientists right so there was a
pretty good match and that you know
obviously they know a lot about rail but
a little bit less about data and we know
almost nothing about rail but a heck of
a lot about data so we were able to
marry those two things together and have
a really good partnership and of course
that's one of the keys for this seminar
series is the point that I think the
analysis here a big data analysis is
probably still further advanced than
just about anywhere else yeah I think so
and I mean you know in Asia particularly
there's a lot of really good
technologies in asia but i think the
type of you know analytics that word not
it's not just park either the types of
analytics that happen quite often here
in Silicon Valley in the u.s. it seems
just from anecdotal experience that it's
not quite what's available in in Asia
and right and that's why this company
came all the way across the Pacific to
have a project with a company in Silicon
Valley as opposed to sourcing it
domestically which you know would have
been a lot easier and cheaper probably
if it had existed when you I mean
there's specific terms all different
yeah all right we have I mean you know
we work with with Asian companies and in
particular Japanese companies for a long
time so at the very least we kind of
know how communication and the culture
works and then the other pieces you know
when we need to we hi we have
interpreters and you know all the
documents are translated and so there's
you know so there's that overhead as
well and it still makes it worth doing
right so there's certainly yeah there's
certainly some barriers in particular
you can imagine asian railway companies
don't have people that are you know
really kind of not many people that are
internationally focused right there's a
lot of domestic folks at that that kind
of are you know haven't spent time
abroad and so there's definitely that
challenge but they were all I mean
they're great they are great and we're
still working with them
they're very excited about the
technology what's going on and for a
infrastructure company I would say
they're one of the more progressive
forward-looking companies because you
know infrastructure you you typically
are come its conservative and they don't
want to incorporate too many new things
right for a lot of obvious reasons but
these guys are pretty forward-looking so
it's been it's been a really great
experience working with them yes um so
how many great ideas we have I think we
have you know it's hard to count it
there's new ideas every day right it's
and it depends on how you define ideas
and we're now I'm talking more broadly
than analytics and it's just Parker in
general but you know the scientists are
there because they have great ideas and
they're they're thinking of new things
all the time and you know I'm in
meetings where they're just kind of
inventing as we're talking through these
things are like stop inventing we're
trying to get something done here so
they come up with new ideas all the time
and you know but a lot of them never
come to fruition right I mean that's the
whole thing of innovation is you try a
hundred things and maybe you know if
you're lucky ten of them work and that's
you know that's kind of the hit rate
that we go for so you have to I think
the thing that one of the things that
makes park but also Silicon Valley and
and kind of the mindset here different
than what I find in Asia quite often is
that there's a there's a tolerance for
failure right and the tolerance for
things not going right because you know
you have to try nine things before you
get that one thing correctly where is in
a lot of Asian cultures and I'm not just
talking about Japan but this is also
prevalent in Japan is that if you fail
at something even once then you've got
this mark right and you've got this you
know whether it's a project that you
tried or you know for example if you're
in Japan and you leave a major
corporation you're never going back to
that company at least in that same
position along that same track right
you've kind of tried something different
and now you're in a different track
whereas in the US you can try something
different you can go fail at a start-up
but you
a lot of the lessons learned and come
back in your in a higher position with
better better salary right so there's a
different definitely a different culture
towards coming up with new ideas and and
failing at dumber do you think that
their main motivation for this system
was cost savings or was it a lot of
safety issues that they were concerned
about yeah i think i think it's it's
more about safety and service to the
customer you know obviously they want to
lower costs but i don't think that was
the main motivation you know they're
they're looking at improving service to
the customer and maintaining or if not
improving the safety of what they
provide so i think those two things were
first and then the cost you know
definitely it shouldn't cost a lot more
and ideally would cost less but it
wasn't the main driver for this this
initiative that's interesting because
one of the points about smart grid right
now is that it seems that for the power
companies cost savings is a much bigger
motivator than just about anything else
yeah and it's the same kind of thing
maintenance to know when something is
going going down or even to predict when
it would go down oh and you know that's
so this is very much an improvement in
safety and service yeah absolutely at
thirty aki thanks very much for a really
interesting story of successful
international business this is great
that's really great to see this kind of
new system going up in place we look
forward to hearing you know after they
have really moved it to commercial out
of the development phase would be great
to hear back of what kind of results
they've had on it so everybody if you
had join me how please join me in giving
a round of applause to a key for it
right
you